can I speak so you said you're a
psychologist
yeah
why do you think why do you think why do
you think why do you think men are more
clever what's the psychology behind that
you know it's about to understand who
you are and which energy you have more
female or male of course exist now a lot
of male women where are you where are
you from oh I have a long story I born
in Russia after I live many many years
19 years and I know all about
relationship and we're sure in something
men they're very strong and we need to
respect them and some think women
they're very strong and women were most
drunk and emotional you are right that
men cannot believe Visa with us and we
also give inspiration of men and we have
very big role for men and women just
need to understand what is her role well
my issue is I'm just talking about the
infrastructure Society so it's like if
we're not doing if we're not making the
most money if we're not doing the most
dangerous jobs how can we say we have an
equal impact as men when it comes to
running Society it's the biggest problem
biggest problem there's a problem if men
make less money than women very often
it's disappears sexual attraction
because automatically we are women not
because we want money money from and of
course so it's great I like to receive
gifts help of mine but if men all time
have less money than women he you come
to be her son
he become to be her son and she doesn't
respect him we are women we must respect
men who are stronger and bigger than us
otherwise we can very like him you can
know my son you my cute boy and we
become to be like mother and son and man
inside us he also hid if we are more
stronger because cannot feel correct and
not feel good with us and it's before
many years when we live in cave men go
he take one big meal and say her wife
it's your meal eat it and she cooked and
she did now a woman say you know meal a
meal which you gave me it's not enough I
can make it faster and bigger yeah and
the woman says stay home and Cave take
care about child I go to make hunting I
would recommend I will take a meal and
now I'm uh begin to switch your
headphones just so you know so you take
off that ones you have put those on just
because otherwise it's gonna yeah there
you go by the way I'm curious no by the
way while you were gone did you uh look
up the definition of misogyny no why
would you want me to look well we're
still going on this on this thingy me
saying that if I fit in five if I feel I
don't understand what the issue is it's
my it's an opinion that I have that I
feel there's a lot of things that go
again
but that's that's like me calling
someone fat and not knowing what that is
good if you're doing things are against
women or okay
what is against women like I just want
to know what is against women what do
you mean what is again because you say I
say things that are against women what
is against women can I say something oh
I think I'm not hello I'm not going to
speak for you I can't even speak hello
I'm not going to speak for you it's when
you're online not racism but it's not
like Sexes and Prejudice towards certain
[Music]
and it's okay for me to feel that way
this is my feeling this is my opinion
from this is just off the back of what
you're saying there's some statements
that people can make and as yourself as
a host that you've made it puts the
women in a negative light oh we know
what do women's uh are they true what it
might not be true that's your opinion
you're saying facts and all of that we
can go and Google we're not we're not
allowed to be on off and that's part of
the rules right I'm sure if I could go
on Google right now and bring out
something I can break up some facts same
way this lady here Natalia she's
researched and done some studies she's
got her her area of expertise there's so
many women as well that have contributed
loads of you know perfect things not
perfect things loads of great things in
society look at when you know England
and whatever went to war and all the
soldiers went who were called to come
and help rebuild wait wait wait who is
defending the society though they
couldn't even work in the factories if
the men were defending the society okay
but that's it shows up how they were
part of the infrastructure they were
able to help rebuild
but they still didn't do the thing that
was the most necessary which was
defending Society
now women go out to war now so you know
what's crazy do you know what's crazy
one um women can't become Navy SEALS or
whatever the highest tax a lot because
they can't physically do it and they're
lowering standards of the military
because they want to include women which
I think is a bad thing I think they keep
telling us we're equal to men and we are
not I think they keep saying that we can
do the same things that men can do and
we cannot I don't think that makes me
mean or misogynistic I think it's it's
true there are certain things that
physically women cannot do that only men
can do to a certain degree you have
categories the same way in Olympics
you're not going to put a woman to
compete against a man because
physiologically you can't compete if
there's a weightlifting Championship
women there's a weightlifting
championships women want to sell what do
women do right okay so if you enter a
man's world then compete be a man and if
you can't do it but they don't do that
though the thing is they're going to
have categories women are going to
compete against women men are going to
compete against men when there's a race
you were talking about women can't run
as fast it's been fine we can accept
that so you raise you stay in your lane
you stay in your category correct you
race against those and women can be fast
is women do not do the hardest jobs in
society some women do it's very much an
exception about brain surgeons who are
women
scientists it is the exception it is not
the rule of conventions 80 of things
that are invented were bi and the rest
of the 20 the 20 the remaining 20 are
women what and I just want to know what
is women what is holding us back
how do we know it was actually men who
invented these things because if I came
up with an invention and I said babes um
progress this for me please I'm sure he
would be happy I just want to understand
I just want to understand your premise
so your premise right now is that all
the inventors it was their wives
actually
but it's so crazy because when a woman
accomplishes something we never say oh
it was probably the man behind her in
general and I might do that but but in
general in society right but vice versa
it's like we we say all of the things
that that men have accomplished we
attribute them to women in some way
probably because historically men were
the leaders in society women are told to
be quiet as you mentioned previously we
listen more so even if we do even if we
did invent something it would be the men
to carry it Forward because they are one
of the first one of the earliest
millionaires in in the U.S one of like
the very first millionaire was was a
woman and she I don't remember what she
invented but she eventually yeah yeah
and so and this is like another this is
a I can't I can't answer but I know she
was the first female millionaire and
this is like um this this is a narrative
that woman couldn't have Heist have
couldn't be influential in society that
women could didn't talk it's just
incorrect there are like Cleopatra Joan
of Arc there have always been high IQ
women that have been very impactful in
society there have been
um queens and rulers that men have
traveled thousands of miles to get
wisdom from this idea that women just
could not get ahead is not true it's not
that women are ahead it's not that if
women can get ahead and if we're gonna
go on facts obviously I can't bring up
my facts now but we know that that women
have been silenced in in many situations
if you look at different cultures
different contexts you know women don't
have the same voice or not given the
same voice or the opinion to speak up as
men or even if they do speak they're not
her because we mean your place is to
stay on the side you know be something
no but I'm saying that's not true it's
true in certain contexts
two things can be true at once it that's
the thing we have to look at things in
you know perspective in a big
perspective just because it's not true
here it doesn't mean it's not true but
it's like but it's like whatever but
whenever I like refute a point it's like
you guys are like jumping through hoops
to try to make us the victim I'm not
making you I'm sorry
because you mentioned Nigeria yeah back
in the day if you were to trace it back
into history because she's very right
women have always not Society has never
said and it has never been in law where
women can't do anything yes the reality
is most people throughout history
couldn't do anything it was usually the
elites and the rich people that could do
stuff and the women in those Realms
could do whatever they wanted to do yes
so but were they recognized
of course they were why why do we know
Cleopatra's why do we know why do we
because if you are excellent you will be
celebrated the reason why most people
are not women were oppressed is because
most people were seen as less than all
throughout history at the time yeah so
it wasn't women that were being
oppressed women were being oppressed in
a certain way and men were being
oppressed in a different way I agree
with that I agree with you because even
women I know we're not going to make it
about race but even when we look at race
that was so many people have been kept
oppressed because of race and it's the
same way you can race as a category so
it's a social construct you know women
yes we are physiological you can Mark Us
by the way we are that's women but men
don't necessarily look at your body and
see okay she's women they will look at
you you know you you're talking about
our society society as well how Society
thinks
that's how they look at you as a woman
they would they will put you know
perspectives and mindsets on you because
you're a woman now I think you have a
privilege as a woman I think it's easier
I think you're more if you know
your advantage
no I think as a young woman you have so
much privilege in society more than men
yeah in general yes absolutely
I I agree with that because I have six
brothers and when I first come to
England there are certain comments my
brothers made and they were more like
but it's easier for you being a woman
and I do agree with that there are
certain things special culture it's much
harder for them you know as a man to go
out and start like for us we can get
and like you said we get attracted by so
many men they want to take care of us
it's much easier for us I totally agree
well and there's so many women's
shelters that help us yeah there are no
men's shelters yeah it's true
what are you talking about women's
shelters what the abuse yes there's what
about what about male victims of abuse
because it's a highly disproportionate
no it's actually so so the majority the
majority no no because why the majority
the majority the majority the majority
of abuse is mutual meaning they are both
hitting each other yes and so and so and
you know what's crazy was when they
looked into it they found that one-sided
abuse it was more likely the woman to
hit the man and the man hit the woman
and the other part we don't talk about
is all the false abuse allegations
especially in this country because there
are incentives for women to falsely
accuse men of abuse because what they do
is they expand the definition of abuse
and to goddamn anything they have
Financial abuse emotional abuse they've
expanded it and what what they do is
there is incent Financial incentives for
women to falsely accuse men
because they get free lawyers in child
support or in um Family Court I'm not
taking that away for you from you but
the percentage is extremely small so no
it's actually exactly so it's actually
it's a roughly I can't remember exactly
but it's around for roughly 10 to 20
percent of women that file abuse and
family court actually go to criminal
court and in family court it's based on
a balance of probabilities that's
actually not based off of evidence but
it's not it's not based on I'm guilty
it's basically guilty until proven
innocent or vice versa and I have a lot
of experience interviewing these guys
and family
organizations out there that do support
male men can be victims of domesticated
however however it's because of society
how we've used how we view men men are
meant to be strong you're meant to be a
leader oh my God no way can a man come
forward and say my wife abuses me yes
you're right there's so many categories
when it comes to domestic abuse not just
physical it can be Financial it can be
mental it can be so many other you know
aspects so a man will feel shame a
mouthful shame you know God forbid he's
to come out and say oh my God I mean
there are organizations that do support
them I don't know about shelters
real quick yes to your point are women
better at some things than men yes for
example for example if you and I were to
box I would probably win but I can
almost guarantee you that you can suck
[__] better than I can
what do you not have a mouth it's the
same mouth that you're going to use if
you're going to suck [__] isn't it so
who's it what that's the same house
I have a conversation and be mature I
have a bottom lip and I have a top lip
and I have a tongue so do you so if you
want to suck [__] you go ahead and do
that I'm not gonna compete with you now
if you don't want to have a mature
conversation I'm being mature
I don't know how we went from domestic
abuses
that's just the silly
I'm not sure
I'm not one to intervene but I came here
invited to this podcast
literally I I got here it took me two
hours to drive here I looked at no
disrespect to anybody but I've never
been to this part of London I'm
petrified even getting out of my car
here I don't belong in this side of the
world I belong in the countryside I I
gotta now get out in the dark get to my
car with this dude security guy who I
love thank you you're gonna take me to
my car but I did not come here to have
conversations about cook I don't even
use them if somebody is back to your
wife like that we told you would you
like that if another one would you
actually agreeing with you no no that's
not how you agree
sorry I'm so sorry
about [__] if you need to understand
Italian
Natalia
[Applause]
[__] wait wait wait King go ahead
um guys please can we just remember the
rules yeah I get it we're all having fun
but let's just try and because we have
people at home watching yeah
it's disrespectful to me but hold on
I've raised my hand so I do want to make
a point next yeah wait what did you say
before I just want to ask you she said
men think about pocket with the time so
I just want to carry on with my point
I'm making no problem and going off on a
point you said I mean this is not why I
came here on this podcast to talk about
[__] and whatever and not to me I do
find that disrespectful yes cook is
aware of everyone who use that however
the point that I was made I didn't
remember the point I was making before
because at your point I found it
disrespectful it's not very lazy
you telling me Oh you don't know if
things come on I can't control the
entire time we can't we can't but we're
talking about respectful that was part
of the rules but we need to respect each
other and I felt disrespected if
somebody came and spoke too off about
that being a married man is that would
you be happy about that as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible